to the point of what he's talking with
libya do you are you should should we be
involved should we not be involved i
would say you know that whole stat we
did with how many military bases we have
versus china around the world you know
how many military bases u.s has around
the world versus how many china has do
you know
i don't want you to say because you know
do you know what the number is 90. how
many u.s has worldwide versus china how
many think china i don't think
five how many do you think u.s has
thousands okay u.s has 800 military
bases worldwide china has won and it's
by the what do you call it djibouti baby
the djibouti by uh suez canal what do
they call that suez canal but there's a
the
oil you know that whole uh section is
what they have they have one military
base u.s has 800.
we have 30 cents the horn of the tip of
africa the the northern part of yeah
yeah that's right that's right that's
right yeah not the suez canal 30
30 000 soldiers in korea 30 000 soldiers
cam casey is one of them yeah japan
40 000 in germany
didn't we win those wars why are we
still there south korea is rich it could
defend itself from norway we might find
out this weekend why there are some in
europe
but nato how does that talk about play
out
we've mobilized a ton of of the navy
there but i don't think anything happens
there's massive amounts of the navy
headed straight there
and we're going to go to war over
ukraine it doesn't sound like it
somebody was not well either somebody
wasn't briefed or somebody gaffed at the
podium so john
what should we be involved in what
should we not be involved in should we
be involved in anything
direct threats to the united states how
about direct threats to allies of the
united states well we have to because we
signed the nate the nato treaty so then
but these treaties which sound wonderful
we're gonna have a safer world it means
we're obligated to go to war for people
we
may no longer like
how do you mean by no longer like maybe
you sign the treaty when one
government's in power and it totally
changes but once government does
something it never undoes it back to
your original question about direct
threats or your point about direct
threats of the united states
wholeheartedly agree look what happened
in 911 that was a direct threat next
thing you know we'd have end up in
afghanistan for 20 years longest war
we've ever been in and that's been a
disaster when they pulled out a little
premature
but at what point is that direct threat
just continue and continue and continue
and continue to the point where it just
makes no sense to be there
well part of the threat continues
because they hate having our
troops
walking down their street how would you
feel if some chinese soldier in uniform
is patrolling your neighborhood would
hate it of course but we want to kill
them but wait a minute that's not always
true it's not always true i'm sorry i
disagree that's not always true because
there are many countries who feel safer
with seeing our troops walking around
than their own troops walking around
because there is that abuse tyler
had we maintained a presence in libya do
you think that this would have degraded
to the extent that it has
no i don't think it would have but but
you know
to the point
i think when you're the largest
superpower in the world the number one
superpower in the world it is your job
to play police officer to keep people in
check and to keep a sort of world order
i mean and let's not forget that's what
these military people sign up for is to
to maintain peace and essentially save
the world i mean that's what they sign
up for
i i i agree with you and i agree with
john this is the part this we're going
to call today's shows the the the the
contradictions
people are like
and at what point does a non-direct
threat become a direct threat so russia
moves into ukraine all right it's not a
direct threat well what if they keep
moving and advancing and eventually move
into all of europe didn't then does it
become a direct threat at what point do
these threats switch to where it's on
our radar yeah i mean
back in 1938 they were like 1939 they're
like okay all right jeremy you you can
have czechoslovakia but you better stop
there
no poland for you
and britain had to go it alone but they
gave him they were like okay we'll let
you absorb one little country
but when you give a little inch you know
you never know how these things are
going to progress and there's something
to be said for china
watching very closely i sent you an
article last night
there's something to be said for
watching very closely to whether or not
if putin does something is this going to
be seen as an opportunity for xi jinping
to do something with taiwan
and to have a coordinated effort
look putin and xi jinping don't like
each other they're not they're not like
hanging out on the weekends
you don't think that they're they're not
buddy buddies no they're two egomaniacs
but that being said
you know if you're talking about kicking
a country when it's down or taking
advantage of a point of vulnerability
then why wouldn't you do it at the same
time
would you say that putin and
and uh she or even china and russia are
more closer to allies or foes
i would say that their interests are
aligned right
they're you saying who china and russia
china and russia they're they're close
they have to get along economic yeah
economically they're kind of like u.s
and mexico yeah u.s and canada let me
ask you who do you think they hate more
do you think russia hates america more
or china more
oh america okay so china you think china
hates russia or america okay so that's
right that part the enemy of miami and
most people on mainland china believe
exactly what they've been told their
entire lives and that's that taiwan is
legally
part of china so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]